okay Oh so guys I'm cute and I'm on the
set ability blind and today I'm gonna go
to burrito
with my boy Blake its up everybody but
the only thing is if I touch any
ingredients on the table I've got to use
it and that's making me kind of nervous
I'm gonna be the eyes you gotta be the
ears and hands and well it's pretty much
mostly on you I mean it's mostly on you
bro
I mean it I can't see listen carefully
we got this we got I'm excited we're a
duo we roll outside of work that's where
a horrible do outside work we get denied
all time in two clubs tonight all the
time in the club I get politely turned
down so we're gonna start with we're
gonna start with where the the tortilla
has to reach out right in front of you
right in front you feel the tortilla yes
now get the whole circumference of the
tortilla for me make sure you know where
the middle of the tortilla is okay first
up put your right hand up no like in
front of you all right so we're gonna
start actually go down down down right
there now reach for it look for the
spoon grab that whole bowl no go grab
that whole bowl hopefully yeah and
there's a spoon in there grab that put
two scoops of that on the burrito
there's a force it's hard bro yeah this
is okay may burst yeah a couple of st.
lettuce bro I'm not filling in blue
couloir whatever it's not even an option
let us not an option listen just just
let's just make this burrito the best we
can I'm gonna say maybe like five scoops
of that and that's still gonna be not
enough oh this is beans probably yeah
those are the buddy those are the black
beans okay put your hand back out okay
let's move left left left down down do
you feel a bowl grab that whole bowl you
know you don't even know
just bacon I could really be messing
with you right now I couldn't Blake
you're gonna eat it too please don't
it smells like peanut butter what is
this it's peanut butter
uh-uh no it's rice oh hell yeah okay how
many scoops I would say two scoops of
rice I'm over the I'm over the bowl no
you need to move back closer to you
right there right later right that's
good that's good we got this we got this
okay one more little little drop there
we go we're low we're heavy on rice it's
all right oh okay this ain't a boat late
baby
okay so put it put your hand out okay go
left all the way so our left but no
don't you go up up go away from you no
that's that's that's towards you okay no
what does that mean oh wait there you go
down go down but don't hit that spoon
there's a bowl behind the spoon right
there's a bowl behind the spoon Oh Bobo
behind this yeah we know come in a
little closer
there you go get that bowl right there
that's your bowl me yeah all right so
let's go two scoops of that
what is it smell like what is it don't
you smoke anything hey Taylor made this
food for us it doesn't smell like
anything Taylor there's a salt this is
Taylor right here everyone let's go one
more height we got this man we're doing
good it's chicken that's chicken yes
it's chicken there's a little bit on the
fork or whatever but there it'll fall
off to you okay no it's not go ahead and
get another big there you go give them
one of those okay that's good that's
good go ahead and put that back and put
away your hand is that'll work okay okay
put your hand down go oh no one hand we
can't do this two handed what's wrong
with you uh go down back towards you a
little bit over to the right and then
down Oh No yeah right down that's it let
you how to use it
no do you were talking too much I mean
no that's good that's the mix like
peppers and stuff and onions
what am I looking like two of these want
to be I'm thinking two of them try to
get a nice spread in there yeah I kind
of because we're kind of just throwing
it in the middle we need to like yeah
okay yeah that's good put it back
hmm okay we have a problem from here
we're gonna have to guess which one is
the sour cream
okay so put your hand out don't go down
stay up for me for a minute go left
Oh God okay go up no like a go Oh go
down and grab that bottle right there
you threw that bottle yeah grab that and
squirt it on the burrito we have no
voice I have no idea what that is it
looks a little soy sauce see there's a
cap on it you got to take the cap on
I feel like they're tricking me or
actually you said this one like you said
look like soy sauce Halos soy sauce yeah
yeah that might not be bad on a burrito
where we go yeah so I mean give it a
little squirt bro yeah get that going
I'm not sure if it's coming out a lot oh
it's coming out that's good
we put a lot of that on there so that's
not gonna be bad right now we just have
a agen like dinner it's fine okay we're
going for the sour cream okay so okay
over there so move a little bit to your
left straight down not another time go
to the right
okay here we go yeah new new new tactic
sounds down down you can go down you got
it you got this it's gonna be a little
Bowl there you go you get that little
Bowl okay okay so give us like two
scoops of that we can taste it and let
us know what it is after you put it on
there no cuz it was a smell like cool it
okay give us two scoops of that okay we
have to eat this dude okay nice definite
sweet okay it's gonna mix well with soy
sauce Oh bro this is getting horrible
now we did we restarted so good but I'm
still making a burrito I'm not trying to
change this up oh and it's like s'more
look I mean as goodbye so but in this oh
it's gonna be bad we got this we got
this
okay go actually just come straight back
towards you from where your hand is
right now go down right there where
you're at I'm gonna Bowl down below you
keep my hand nice and tight yeah you're
gonna go into the guacamole but yeah I
keep going down you got the bowl that's
the ball touching it this one yeah
that's it you want to put two scoops of
that on there this is a real dedication
I'm slightly allergic to avocado oh okay
yeah that's good for that okay so now
we're gonna go salsa but this one's
tough because it's little remember when
we were going for a little one there's
their bottles and stuff in there yeah we
gotta be careful you know real careful
you got a direct me right like okay
awesome I handy we got options here yes
stay high I think with the pointing down
thing I'm down for it it's like the claw
ah okay come back towards you stop good
no stop this could be really bad go up a
little bit like no I gotta get away from
the table I don't trust it yeah I'm
sorry okay hold your hand up higher
okay go go come towards the camera okay
too far why why are you moving that fast
man we got a good down
they coming up oh my god you're gonna
hit the guacamole and I'm gonna get sick
just get me as close as possible and
then directly to the right Island I
can't I don't have very little depth
perception
Oh who did you pick lose you limey look
again this is why we fell out of clubs
so go go down down down
oh yeah we're getting close well keep it
down
keep going you're gonna hit a bowl and a
spoon that's it yeah I don't have deaf
perception for going down you
blindfolded too I'm I gotta watch a
screen so the swords upside down okay
yeah okay go ahead and give us two
spoonfuls of that I don't like them less
also okay just put one then it's a good
amount of salsa then well yeah so we got
rice beans chicken mixed peppers and
onions guacamole salsa and sour cream
that's not sour cream but yeah but
that's what we're going for so I think
the only thing we have left is cheese
right okay
for just for just two let's let's change
things up make things hard switch hands
what lay hands bro we are ready for
dubbing up bro come on let's wait
there's no turning like sauce and
whipped cream on like I said like is the
reason why we fell okay so go up
straight go to your right right right
right right right down go yeah go a
little fee I keep going down you're
gonna feel it
you feel it that's your bowl
that's your bowl yeah that's it what is
this chi Chi's load it up yeah go ahead
go ahead and do one more of those you
like a tasty chef right now look at you
oh yes
cheese BAE
how about you boy cheese baby okay so
now the only thing left is hot sauce and
I'm not gonna lie to you they're in
bottles it's the one on the right
they're both is that what we're going
with
okay I'll trust you is the one on the
right okay and I'm like neo bro in the
matrix when he went blind but he can
still people up you know I'm saying
that's me right now it's my right let's
do it
yeah that Nyoka seizure yeah go to your
right
Oh God okay to your left but a little
bit a little bit
okay straight down straight down yeah
that one that's the one on the right
[Music]
okay yeah wait what if he's like level
today I saw look at that both hotdogs
but one is like hot sauce this is both
hot one looks like ketchup but if you
touch it we have to put it on there so
you're just gonna have to guess I think
this house oh no let's hope all right so
give this like a good squirt of that you
know
[Music]
all right I think we're good I think
we're good okay op touching things bro
he's gonna make us put gummy worms in
there anywhere put your hands if I touch
it so if you keep on playing around
we're gonna end up with this guy motives
photo we're ready to start rolling our
burrito up but right did you ever work
in a burrito place I never did I don't
know how to do this you watch him learn
buddy I thought you put too much on here
is what I'm owed again I put too much on
here because you were directing me oh
dude do that I would have made it light
I kept it light pretty good job I'm
surprised this is like fantastic see my
role or nobody rolling
I made a burrito before yeah this is not
bad breath he watched a YouTube video no
I worked I worked before all right I
think we're good I think we're good
[Laughter]
whipped cream one the only thing we
messed up with was the whipped cream
honestly I can't taste the whipped cream
maybe you got the whipped creams on my
trip big up be a pretty good job Oh moon
I think they're cool with was that Anna
nice you must got a cool website
different flavors are coming out you
starting to get weird
I got towards the end but overall not
bad people
soy sauce is actually really good I
actually think that that should be a new
[Music]
why did you take a second buy it no oh
hey check it out I think we did pretty
good then we came out strong right yeah
I mean I think that we would
communicated well I thought that I kept
all the inside of the things we did we
did we did
make too much of a mess until the end
there I mean you do have whipped cream
in your hair now do it yeah it's a
little victories yeah
[Music]